wie ist die Lage die Lage ich habe
gestern in in im Fernsehen gehört ich
guck ja selten Fernsehen weil ich so die
Zeit nicht habe wegen meiner ganzen
sozialen Kontakte und die sagten dass
die Wirtschaftslage jetzt ungefähr so
sein wird wie seit Zweiten Weltkrieg so
schlecht und ich muss sagen das schlecht
natürlich auch auf unseren berufeder ne
ganz klar ich werde mal sagen die Lage
ist
nicht hoffnungslos aber schon ganz schön
im roten bere ich gibt's weniger Buchung
im Moment ja ja klar we man merkt das
schon deutlich deutlich weil du bist ja
jemand der nimmt was was kommt also wenn
ich du hast x Filme hast du gedreht
Serien Comedys Serien alles mögliche
prom pilgern habe ich gesehen also das
POM da muss ich noch drauf eingehen weil
das das war wirklich so das war da war
da hätte man da wä man doof gewesen also
wirklich richtig doof wenn man es nicht
gemacht hätte er erstens war es
finanziell eine klasse Angebot weil im
Prinzip jeden Wandertag J den Tag des
wandern wie ein Drehtag bezahlen wollten
und das war ist natürlich ein tolles
Angebot und dann war das eine der
geilsten Erfahrungen die ich irgendwie
in meinen 47 Jahren Leben gemacht habe
und die Leute zu Hause also die meisten
Kumpels wieder getroffen habe die sagt
du bist irgendwie verändert irgendwie
mental strahlt zu und anderes aus danach
habe ich natürlich ein bisschen
nachgehagt du bist nicht mehr so
hektisch im Moment man sieht ja es hat
sich wieder alles verändert ich bin
wieder genauso hektisch wie
früher aber das hat wohl schon irgendwie
wirklich was dieses Jahr würde ich ins
Auge fassen noch mal zu tun wow wirklich
wow wirklich du hast ja auch eine Menge
Drogenerfahrung ist das wie eine Droge
so eine Wanderung oder was unterscheidet
es
das unterscheidet es dass man dass man
dass man bei dieser Pilgerei war das
eher etwas etwas was auflöst etwas was
Knoten
wegmacht und die Drogengeschichten sind
natürlich immer Sachen die die also
letztendlich konsequenterweise
untergestrich immer Knoten machen und
zwar
gesundheitliche Knoten also Knoten im
Sinne von negativen
Strangulation gesundheitlich finanziell
sozial letztendlich auch kopfmäßig und
so da ist das P natürlich wesentlich
gesünder ja es ist halt so dass ich eben
halt irgendwie auch in dieser
Öffentlichkeit in der ich stehe eben Hal
auch sehr als sehr verletzlicher Mensch
unterwegs bin
dass ich mit vielen Sachen
sagen mal vielleicht sogar schlechter
zurechtke als als so gewisser in
Ermangelung eines besseren Wortes
Durchschnittsmensch das ist aber trotz
allem zu meinem Paket dazu gehört das
ist einfach so ich bin so geschnürt und
und kann da nicht einfach auspacken und
einpacken so wie ich lustig bin sonder
muss schon einfach auch zugeben dass
auch meine schauspielerische Intensität
oder Intention natürlich auch viel mehr
mit Leid und Trauer zu tun hat als mit
Lust und Spaß also auch wenn man mich
oft als Comedian sieht oder so hat
nichts damit zu tun dass ich im Grunde
genommen elich ein lustiger Mensch bin
also ich bin so nicht so ein bumsfalder
Typ wie es vielleicht manchmal so
rüberkt du hast gerade gesagt Leid und
Trauer gehören zu diesem Beruf ja ja
warum warum so ist das so wichtig na ja
ich glaube was einfach eben halt einfach
ganz oft so ein unterschätztes Ding ist
was man so an an an also Leid und Trauer
so ein bisschen so weggeschoben wir
jetzt genauso wie der Tod und alle diese
Diskussionen in unserer Gesellschaft ist
aber eine ziemliche triebfehler die wir
eigentlich haben nur wird eben gerne
davon wegeguckt weil in unserer
Gesellschaft natürlich meistens
derjenige ein toller Typ ist der gut
drauf ist ne mm wie kommt deine Familie
mit dir zurecht als Mensch der das alles
so bewusst erlebt
ja das liegt natürlich auch oder das ist
fängt natürlich da an wo ich mich schon
mal so als Familienvater schon so gar
nicht so richtig einstufen kann weil man
fragt m natürlich wie gehst Du z.B
deinen Kindern um erziehst du da gehen
bei mir schon die Alarmglocken an weil
ich eigentlich merke ich erzieh gar
nicht ich ich bin eigentlich gar nicht
so jemand der dann wirklich da ja das
ist ein scheiß Thema weil weil bist du
zu sehr Künstler dazu Scheiße ja ich WE
ist die Familie mehr so ein Anhängsel
was jetzt einfach entstanden ist und
aber das ist gut also das mit dem
Anhängsel und dem entstanden ist ist
richtig das ist richtig ja also ich bin
nicht auf der Suche gewesen mir mir wie
ich das z. V meinen Eltern kenne die
gesagt haben wir wollten ganz klar sagen
19 20 21 wollte ich meine meine Lehre zu
Ende haben da wollte ich einen netten
Mann und nette Frau kennenlernen und
eine Familie gründen das hatte ich nie
aber es hatten viele nie glaube ich das
ist irgendwie das ist das hatte ich nie
und ich bin in einer unglaublich netten
Familie groß geworden wo ich eigentlich
normalerweise sagen müsste wenn ich mich
von außen betrachte das war eigentlich
eigentlich so ein schöner Hafen so ein
so eine eine sichere Zeit die mir da
geboten wurde eigentlich müsste ich den
großen Anspruch haben das weiterzugeben
aber ich hatte nie das Bedürfnis zu
sagen ich brauche jetzt jetzt irgendwie
zwei Kinder oder ein Kind oder drei
Kinder den ich das wiedergeben kann ich
hatte keinen keinen nicht diesen Input
und dann waren sie plötzlich da und wie
ist das jetzt es ist natürlich so dass
ich natürlich ganz ehrlich gesagt und
das natürlich jetzt wieder blablabla
aber es ist wirklich nicht so gemeint
ich lieb sie natürlich von ganzem ganzem
Herzen und wenn irgendwas passieren
würde
was was was tragisch wäre ich hätte
wirklich nicht die geringste Ahnung
damit umgehen würde wenn ich jetzt
parallelen schlagen soll zu solchen
amläufen die ist
eine also eine eine emotionale
Katastrophe ich habe nie na also da muss
ich wirklich sagen ich bin wirklich
selten sprachlos aber da bin ich einfach
sprachlos auch wenn Kinder wegkommen und
man weiß nicht wo sie sind oder so äh äh
da bin ich manchmal habe ich manchmal
schon den Verdacht dass ich dass ich
wenn ich über mich nachdenke schon
deswegen keine Kinder wollte weil ich
mir einfach auch diesen Schmerz hätte
irgendwie ersparen wollen einfach gar
nicht diese Verluste haben wenn ich gar
ke nichts zum Verlieren habe und jetzt
habe ich sie da wenn ich an meine beiden
denke wenn ich mir vorstellen W diese
Gesichte W irgendwann mal nicht mehr in
meinem Leben
das also katastrophal ist ist ja schon
alleine deswegen weil ich natürlich
jetzt irgendwie ein Vergleich den MAN SE
sicherlich irgendwie total schändlich
findet aber ich hatte z.B mal einen
Mischlingshund den ich 15 Jahre lang
hatte ich habe deswegen keine Tiere mehr
weil ich diesen Verlust nicht noch mal
erleben will der ist mir dann irgendwann
mal gestorben nach 15 Jahren nur ein
Hund aber das meine ich noch mal mit
deswegen meine Kinder wollen Andau
Katzen und Andau und irgendwelche Tiere
und ich verweiß auch gerne D dass die
der Wunsch irgendwie aber das meine
Nummer diese ne das
war wie ist das dann überhaupt in der
Patchwork Fam family weil Familie du
hast ja zwei Töchter noch aus der ersten
Beziehung deiner Freundin die Leben auch
bei Euch oder sie unterwegs oder ganz
genau sieht so aus dass die Luna meine
erste 12 Jahren jetzt in wieder im
Ruhrgebiet wohnt mit meiner Exfrau aber
eben regelm ich in Berlin ist mit ihrem
eigenen Zimmer und auch gerne da ist in
Berlin ist dann meine jetzige Partnerin
die eine 20-jährige und ein 12jährigen
mitgebracht haben der 12jährige wohnt
noch bei uns 20jährige ist gerade raus
und mit dieser Frau mit der ich zusammen
in Berlin lebe habe ich jetzt noch mal
zusammen einen zweijährigen und da ist e
mal alles dabei alles dabei und und und
da haben die Leute Hal immer ach wie
schön wie bunt und und da muss ich
wirklich sagen das ist das ist wieder
sowas wo ich wieder mal wieder ehrlich
sein muss muss dann sagen muss das
einfach eine unglaublich erschreckende
Arbeit ist von der ich nicht gewusst
habe dass es so ist ich habe z.B das ist
jetzt auch eine Beichte dafür darauf bin
ich auch nicht stolz aber
das muss ich einfach sagen ist z.B diese
Geschichte die man früher mal gesagt
bludisticker als Blut istticker als
Wasser es ist schon so dass man dass ich
nicht ich weiß nicht ob ich jetzt sagen
soll mann oder ich nur aber es ist schon
komisch wenn man eigengeborene Kinder
hat und Kinder die einem
die dazu gekommen sind oder die man
geschenkt bekommen hat oder die einem
aufgebordet worden sind wenn man sich in
die ich habe mich ja nicht in den in den
in den Jungen und in die Tochter
verliebt ich habe mich ja in die Frau
verliebt und dann sagt natürlich jeder
na ja klar wenn du dich eine Frau
verliebst dann musst du natürlich auch
alles gleichzeitig lieben was sie
mitbringt ist ja Quatsch nicht dass ich
jetzt dem anderen irgendwie
ungerechter bin ganz im Gegenteil
manchmal bin ich sogar toleranter dem
dem den den also den anderen beiden
gegenüber weil ich denke so wenn ich
meinen beiden da irgendwie netter bin
dann fliege ich ja komplett auf also
also bin ich manchmal strenger mit
meinen eigenen Kindern blutmäßig nur
damit ich eben mal zeigen kann so ich
bin gerecht man hört ja immer von allen
Seiten irgendwie das geht ganz einfach
und ich habe gedacht na klar geht das
einfach du hast die Frau lieb sehr lieb
sogar du wirst alles dafür tun dass die
dass es als Beziehung funktioniert also
nimmst du do alles mit was da an Ballas
dabei ist in anführungstrichen aber das
war dann plötzlich als der Alltag
eintrat plötzlich schwieriger als ich
erwartet hatte was sagt sie dazu
es ist es ist es ist nicht auffällig
also es ist nicht so dass ich dass es
auffällig ist sie weiß gar nichts davon
eigentlich wenn wenn ich sie nicht
gebeichet gebeichtet hätte würde sie es
nicht wissen nein weil es ist natürlich
ganz klar dass ich dass ich da als
bewusster Mensch ganz klar weiß dass das
so nicht geht natürlich nicht und das
ist mit der Patchwork Familie so dass
dass da die Romantisierung komplett
ausfällt das ist wirklich richtig harte
Arbeit und dann kommen noch so
Geschichten wie wir fahren in Urlaub
habt ihr es gut ich sag ist Horror der
eine will an Strand der andere will in
die Berge der eine will zu Hause bleiben
der eine will Fisch der eine will Pizza
der andere will Spaghetti der andere
will gar nichts
Horror und da ist wirklich also nichts
Romantisches dabei aber ich bin auch wie
schon gesagt also
habe also kein Erziehungskonzept ich
möchte dass meine Kinder gute Menschen
werden ich möchte dass sie z.B Bitte und
Danke sagen dass sie wenn z.B Alter
alter Menschen die uahn einig in Platz
anbieten solche Kleinigkeiten und zwar
sie das aus Reflex tun aus Herzensgüte
und nicht weil es irgendwo steht oder
möchte nicht dass sie so so ein wasollst
du soll ich nicht schnutz sagen oder was
das möchte ich nicht da möchte ich auch
alles dagegen tun dass ist aber sie
werden halt solchen Leuten groß zu 98%
glaube ich ne ist übrigens auch was was
ich meinen Kindern gerne mitgeben würde
ein ein was für die fürs Leben und zwar
der Satz der andere könnte auch recht
haben das ist für mich auch ein
grundkern meiner meiner
Lebenseinstellung Achtung Ausrufezeichen
der andere könnte auch recht haben ja
guckst du denn auch noch splätterfilme
ja klar wir nehmen uns natürlich da
nicht ernst im Sinne von sondern wir
lieben dieses diesen diesen diese
Monstrosität der Fantasie dieses überboh
abstruse dieses dieses dieses human
Fiction das ist das was uns oder uns
Horrors Fenster oder SP Fans
irgendwie verbindet was wir ich habe
also bei allen meinen Freundin die mir
ernst waren s meine Hand voll ich bin
echt ke Frauen hält also auch mit allen
one stand und so da komme ich nicht auf
da komme ich also nicht auf besonders
viele da könn ich ke Buch drüber
schreiben also die die mir wirklich
ernst waren mit ich auch darüber
gesprochen habe warum ich gerne solche
Sachen sehe oder lese oder so kon es nie
erklären habe mich immer bemüht zu
erklären warum bis ich dann irgendwann
aufgegeben habeag entweder du du kommst
jetzt mit guckst mittlerweise so dass
ich nur noch alleine in solche Filme
gehe weil es ist natürlich unglaublich
unerotisch wenn der Zombie die Tür
Eintritt mit einer Kettensäge die
Familie niedermetzelt der Vater ihm die
Mikrowelle auf den Schädel Haut und die
Mikrowelle anspringt und das Monster
stirbt und deine Freundin neben dir sagt
jetzt aber unlogischich der ganze Film
kaputt wir müssen Schluss machen wir
können glaub ich noch ewig reden ja
stimmt viel Erfolg auf jeden Fall bei
der Kinder zehung auch wenn sie
vielleicht unbewusst läuft aber
offensichtlich erfolgreich ah das ist
nicht so schlecht ja das nehme ich gerne
mit danke schön